the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 video today I want to talk about one
of my videos that I made over a year ago
I'm assuming that most of you did see
that video because it has nearly half of
a million views as of right now that
video was called the top 10 missing
characters that are still alive in this
show the reason why I want to talk about
this again is because I haven't talked
about most of these characters in a very
long time now that the final season is
just right around the corner I'm
wondering if any of you think any of
these characters will actually make a
return to the show next season also make
sure you stay until the very end of the
video because I will be announcing the
winner of the new giveaway but let's get
started like I said there are a bunch of
different characters who we haven't seen
in quite some time now the chances of
these characters ever returning might be
very slim but since they are technically
still alive then there is always a
chance of them showing back up in the
story once again the first character I
talked about in that video was Jack in a
gar and that was mainly because he has
been missing for the least amount of
time we did see him at the very end of
season six when Arya Stark left Braavos
but we never did see him during last
season you have to keep in mind this was
a character that we met at the very
beginning of the second season of the
show Jack and Garr had been in the story
for a very long time so would be kind of
disappointing if we never did see him
again now of course there is one very
interesting thing about Jack and agar he
has the ability to change his face so we
might have actually seen him last season
without even knowing it was him as we
all know he was the key figure in Arya
Starks character development since Arya
Stark is still alive and kicking we
could very well see Jack and show up
where Arya would least expect it with
only six episodes left we don't have
that much time but since this character
has always been a fan favorite I am
hoping the showrunners have one final
act for our old friend Jack and agar let
me know if you think we will ever see
him again another character when that
was on that lace
was can vara the last time we saw her
was also during season six when she met
with Varys and Tyrion now if you
remember that scene it did seem like in
Varro was about to become a regular
character in the story but obviously we
haven't seen her since what she said to
Varys has always made me think that we
would see her again as we all know Varys
has been a major player ever since the
first season of the show and we know
what happened to Varys when he was a
child has haunted him ever since you
heard a voice call out from the flames
do you remember should I tell you what
the voice said should I tell you the
name of the one who spoke during that
scene can Vora made one thing very clear
she knows what the voice in the flame
said to Varys
ever since she revealed that she knew
his secret I am hoping that she will
eventually tell all of us as well now
the good thing is we do know that
Melisandre is on her way to volantis
which is most likely where Canberra is
located now whether or not Melisandre
returns with Canberra is still unknown
but we all know she had to go there to
get someone or something
since kinvaras is a very high-ranking
member from the faith of real or I think
the chances of her returning to the show
are very good let me know if you think
she will return with Melisandre the next
character that was mentioned was Illyrio
also known as viserys and danerys is
sugar daddy I'm still not exactly sure
when we last saw him but I believe it
was during the first season when Arya
Hofer heard him speaking with Varys now
as far as we know this character should
still be alive and he obviously had some
very close ties to Varys their plans
were set in motion before the events a
game of Thrones even begun since Varys
is still in the show you have to wonder
if he is still corresponding with
Illyrio in some way now we do know that
they had been talking for quite some
time because Varys took Tyrion to his
house and the fifth season after they
fled King's Landing in the books Tyrion
spends a lot of time with Illyrio but we
never did see their interactions in the
show that makes me wonder where the hell
did that character go
he was basically the caretaker of Dany
and Viserys for a number of years he
didn't even help them set up the wedding
between Daenerys and Khal Drogo but one
of the most important things he did was
give
Daenerys her dragon eggs now that those
dragons are fully grown and Daenerys has
went on to become a queen in her own
right you would think she would have
reached out to him at some point over
the course of seven seasons since we
haven't seen him and so long we may
never see him again
but I did not forget about him the next
character has never actually been seen
in the show except for one of bran
Starks flashbacks and that is Howland
Reed now I did just recently talk about
this character in one of my last videos
so I will try to keep it short what we
do know is he is Meera and Jojen Reed's
father and he was also one of Ned
Stark's best friends as far as we know
he is the only character that is still
alive who was present at the Tower of
joy well except for Jon Snow but he
doesn't remember any of it
we know that Howland Reed was alive at
the time of Ned Stark's death because
Jojen told us that he did see his father
cry when he heard the news when I told
my father about your father the first
time in my life I saw him cry
your father is Howland Reed since Meera
Reed was on her way home last season
maybe she will cause her father to show
up in this story next season I imagine
that mirror will tell him about brains
flashbacks and the return of the White
Walkers hopefully this will get Howland
Reed to show up in Winterfell and tell
us everything that he knows not only can
he confirm the truth about Jon Snow's
parents but he might also hold some
information that can help against the
night king some of you may not know this
but Howland Reed actually spent some
time on the Isle of faces or the gods
eye since that location has a very large
network of weirwood trees and there is
no telling what Howland Reed may know
about the White Walkers or just a future
in general I don't know about you but I
would love to find out what Howland Reed
was able to learn when he was there
another character we haven't seen since
season six is Ed mere Tolly as we all
know he has been a prisoner of House
Frey ever since the red wedding
thanks to Arya Stark House Frey is on
the verge of extinction
so maybe ed Murtagh Li will gain his
freedom before the show does come to an
end
according to Walder Frey he had ed
mirror locked back up in the cells at
the twins after Jaime had helped them
retake River Run
and me oz back in the south can't go
killing my son by law wouldn't be right
did the family a bad name when we saw
Oreo wipe out the phrase last season I
was hoping she would set him free but
for whatever reason they never did show
that scene I can only assume that's
where he's still at now that almost all
of the men from house frey are dead
maybe one of the daughters or
granddaughters will let him out we also
know that Jamie is most likely on his
way to Winterfell and I believe he may
make a few stops along the way Jamie and
Ed Muir were both in one of the most
well acted scenes of season 6 when we
saw them speak together in the tent
during that scene ed meer did give a
little speech about Jamie and his
character now that Jamie's left Cersei
maybe he will remember what ed Muir had
said to him therefore Jamie might be the
one to set him free but only time will
tell
now this next character is very
mysterious not only in the show but in
the books as well I am of course
referring to a character known as Quaife
from the shadow lands beyond the shy I
know this is a character who I would
love to see again even though she wasn't
in very many scenes she was obviously a
very interesting character although she
did caution sir Jorah Mormont we really
don't know her true intentions in the
books she talks to Daenerys about the
prophecies that have yet to be revealed
that has always made me wonder what her
actual endgame is do I know you I know
you Jorah Mormont of Bear Island who are
you
oh no one but she is the mother of
dragons she needs true protectors now
more than ever there shall come day and
night to see the Wonder born into the
world again and when they see they shall
lust what else does she have in store
for Daenerys Targaryen is she really
trying to help her out or are her
intentions more sinister than we
initially thought I actually don't think
we will ever see her again but I really
wish we could because she would make
things a hell of a lot more interesting
if we could get her in the same room
with characters like Melisandre and
brain stark now that the night King is
on his way I will not be surprised if a
bunch of old characters show up to
provide some type of service let me know
if you think we have seen the last of
quaithe now of course I cannot forget
about that little [ __ ] Robin Arryn I
believe the last time we saw him was
during the fifth season when
Littlefinger and sanso left the Eyrie he
technically has control of the Knights
of the Vale
although Littlefinger was the one who
was actually making all the moves
now that Littlefinger is dead you have
to wonder how Robin Arryn will react to
that news as we all know he was very
fond of Littlefinger after all do you
think there is a chance that he could
try to get the Knights of the Vale to
leave Winterfell for what the Starks did
the Littlefinger
I imagine that songs that would just
tell him that Littlefinger was the one
who killed his mother but she never
quite know what will happen next season
all we can really try to do right now is
make some educated guesses and I put
quotes around educated when it comes to
me even though not too many fans
actually like that character he still
does deserve some type of closure he
does have control over a very large army
that is experienced when it comes to
fighting in the ice and snow he also has
a castle that could come in handy if the
knight King should ever take over
Winterfell
I would like to think that we will see
Robin Arryn again but let me know what
you think another character I can't
forget is Salladhor Sam the long-lost
friend of ser Davos one of the last
times we saw this character is back in
season 4 when Davos and Stannis went to
the iron bank for a loan
thanks to Davos the loan was given the
green light Davos then went to salvador
san and he gave him a nice piece of
change for his services at that time
they needed to use his ships to escort
the sell swords up through the wall
since then I really can't tell you where
this character has went now what's
interesting about this character is he
does say something very important in the
thanks to salad or saying he is the
reason that we found out about how
Lightbringer was made by azor Ahai even
though Melisandre is the one who talks
about that legendary character the most
it's Salladhor san who fills us in on
some of the most interesting details he
is the one who tells Davos the story
about how azor Ahai had to forge a sword
three times before he could create
Lightbringer and of course that third
time was when he stuck his sword in anis
aneesa's chest I was hoping that salad
or sand could tell us that story in the
television show as well but we may never
see him again although we did not see
him die since we will see a lot of
characters travel by sea next season
there is still a slim chance that he
could show up once again we know that
John Danny and Davos are travelling on
the sea as we speak we know that you're
on Greyjoy he has to travel to Essos and
back and we know that Melisandre has to
travel to Essos and back we also know
that fee on Greyjoy will be traveling
around the seas as well so maybe one of
these characters will run into him
somewhere along the way so as you can
see there are still many different
storylines that were left open from over
the years the only problem is we might
not have enough time to visit some of
the minor characters that just seem to
disappear however with most of the main
cast having to travel around Westeros
next season maybe just maybe we will run
into some of our old friends again let
me know which of these characters you
think has the best chances of showing up
again now let's move on to the winner of
the giveaway let's see which one of you
will go home with the ax Song of Ice and
Fire book collection the winner of the
new giveaway is Shannon Dodson
congratulations Shannon just make sure
you send me an email that way I can find
out where I need to send the books if
you did not win today don't worry
because I will be starting a new one
right away just make sure you come back
for the next video to find out all of
those details thanks for watching
today's video I really appreciate that
and I also want to thank everyone on
patreon for supporting the channel I
hope you all have a great day I will see
you again very soon bye
you
[Music]
[Music]